Guten Abend, mein Name ist Aktaqa. Ich bin hier zu ständige Erzitempürze.
Zuerst werde ich zu Ihrer Person ein Endeffelagen stellen.
Dann kommen wir gleich zu Ihrer Aktuellen Becherde.
Wie heißen Sie denn?
Ich heiße Valentina Strohtmann.
Valentina Strohtmann.
Können Sie bitte Ihren Vor- und Nachnamen langsam buchen?
Ja, Valentina schreibt sich V-A-L-E-N-T-I-N-A. Valentina.
Mhm.
Und Strohtmann ist T-R-U-T-H-M-A-N-N. Strohtmann. Ich bin eine Frau.
Vielen Dank. Frau Strohtmann, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 61 Jahre alt.
Und wann genau sind Sie geboren?
Am 12. September 1963.
Wie groß sind Sie?
1,64 m.
Und wie viel wiegen Sie?
65 kg.
Und wie heißt Ihr Hausarzt oder Ihr Hausarzt?
Das ist Frau Dr. Hiller.
Hiller schreibt sich H-I-L-L-E-R.
Danke für die Informationen, Frau Strohtmann. Was führt Sie so ums Heute?
Ja, ich habe seit ungefähr drei Wochen habe ich Schmerzen im rechten Bein.
Und jetzt seit zwei Tagen sind die Schmerzen sehr stark geworden,
sodass ich da gar nicht mehr richtig auftreten kann.
Deswegen komme ich jetzt zu Ihnen.
Sie haben gut gemacht. Seit drei Wochen haben Sie diese Schmerzen
und seit zwei Tagen sind sie schlimmer geworden.
Und genau sind diese Schmerzen im rechten Unterchenkel.
Nein, Sie sind im rechten Bein mehr im Oberschenkel,
und zwar direkt oberhalb vom Knie.
Also am Ende des Oberschenkels, oberhalb vom Knie.
Da ist der Hauptschmerz.
Ich verstehe.
Wie sind diese Schmerzen aufgetrackt, langsam oder plötzlich?
Langsam.
Haben Sie früher so etwas schon diese Schmerzen?
Nein, so was habe ich noch nie gehabt.
Streitende Schmerzen ihr kennt wohl hin aus, in andere Kräfte?
Nein.
Können Sie mir die Schmerzen genauer beschreiben,
sind sie eher dumpf, drückend oder stehend, sehend?
Nein, die sind mehr dumpf.
So dumpfer Schmerz, so tief, tief im Bein drin.
Manchmal auch vielleicht etwas drückend, aber dumpf und drückend.
Ich verstehe.
Und wie stark sind diese Schmerzen auf einer Schmerzskala,
wobei ein sehr leichter und sehr starker Schmerzen jetzt spricht?
Also in den ersten drei Wochen, da waren die Schmerzen
vielleicht zwischen drei und vier.
Aber jetzt, als zwei Tagen, sind sie sechs bis sieben.
Können Sie jetzt diese Schmerzen ertragen oder brauchen Sie sofort ein Schmerzmittel?
Doch, ich habe ein Schmerzmittel probiert, in der letzten Nacht.
Ebu Profen habe ich genommen, zwei Tabletten.
Aber es hat etwas gelindert, aber nicht ausreichend, nicht fehlen.
Wie stark war Ebu Profen? 400 mg?
600, 600.
Er hat etwas geholfen, aber nicht genug.
Gibt es einen bestimmten Auslöser für diese Schmerzen?
Nein, können nicht.
Jetzt, seit zwei Tagen, bewege ich mich nicht mehr groß.
Ich traue mich nicht aufzutreten, weil es dann noch stärker wird der Schmerz.
Aber einen Auslöser, sonst kenne ich nicht.
Gibt es etwas, das die Schmerzen verstärkt oder verstärkt?
Bewegung verstärkt.
Schlimmer.
Sind diese Schmerzen dauerhaft oder gehen sie auch wieder weg?
Nein, die sind dauerhaft.
Verändern die Schmerzen beim Hoch- oder Tieflagerung?
Wenn ich das Bein ganz ruhig hinlege,
vielleicht etwas höher lege,
wenn ich einige Kissen darunter lege,
ist es vielleicht etwas besser.
Nach unten lagern möchte ich nicht gerne.
Wie sieht die Haut aus?
Wie die Haut aussieht, das ist ein bisschen geschwollen,
da an der Stelle, wo der Hauptschmerz ist, oberhalb vom Knie.
Und es ist auch, habe ich den Eindruck, die Haut ist etwas wärmer.
Und gerötet?
Ja, das ist mir jetzt nicht aufgefallen, dass es gerötet ist.
Ihr Bein ist geschwollen und die Haut ist wärmer?
Ja, aber an der Stelle, also da oberhalb vom Knie, am Oberschenkel.
Haben Sie noch andere Bescheide?
Nein, sonst habe ich keine anderen Beschwerden.
Sie haben gegen diese Schmerzen nur Ibuprofen, 2 Tablet, 600 mg eingenommen.
Aber das hat genug geholfen.
Das hat nicht genug geholfen, aber nicht genug.
Frau Strothmann, haben Sie Fieber?
Nein, ich schülle mich nicht an, wie Fieber.
Haben Sie nachschweiß oder Stärkost?
Nein, glaube ich nicht.
Ist mir nicht aufgefallen.
Wie ist Ihr Appetit im Letzterseite?
Der Appetit ist eigentlich ganz gut.
Aber ich habe nichts bemerkt, dass sich da etwas verändert hat.
Haben Sie in Letzterseite ungewohnt oder zu genommen?
Ich glaube nicht, nein. Mein Gewicht habe ich gehalten.
Das würde ich sonst merken an meiner Kleidung.
Haben Sie Schlafstörungen?
Normalerweise schlafe ich ganz gut.
Aber in den letzten Tagen, auch in den Wochen, wo ich diese Schmerzen hatte,
konnte ich manchmal nicht so gut schlafen.
Das Bein hat schon geschmerzt.
Ich verstehe.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Einschlafen oder durchschlafen?
Einschlafen kann ich gut, eigentlich.
Durchschlafen ist da nicht so gut.
Aber das kommt wegen der Schmerzen.
Sonst geht das nie ein Problem.
Haben Sie Probleme mit dem Stuhlgang oder beim Wasserlassen?
Stuhlgang habe ich regelmäßig.
Einmal am Tag Wasserlassen, eigentlich auch okay.
Ich gehe einmal nachts auf Toilette, aber das schon länger
und kann danach in der Regel auch gut wieder einschlafen.
Leiden Sie eine irgendeine kronische Erkrankung?
Ja, ich habe eine chronische Bronchitis.
Da war ich auch schon mal vor einiger Zeit beim Lungenfacharzt
und hat mir ein Gerät verschrieben, ein elektrisches Gerät zum inhalieren.
Da soll ich zweimal am Tag mit inhalieren.
Aber das habe ich nicht regelmäßig gemacht, muss ich ehrlich sagen.
Aber ich habe schon damit zu tun mit diesem chronischen Husten.
Wer für Medikamente inhalieren Sie gegen diese Bronchitis?
Ich habe das jetzt vergessen, das Mittel.
Muss ich Ihnen nachreichen?
Mein Mann kann das von zu Hause mitbringen.
Ich werde zu Ihrer Frau Hausarztin fragen.
Also diese Bronchitis, haben Sie noch andere Erkrankungen?
Ja, ich hatte vor anderthalb Jahren, vor 18 Monaten hatte ich eine Operation.
Da hatte ich, wurde bei mir ein Bronchalkrebs festgestellt.
Und da bin ich operiert worden.
Und anschließend bekam ich eine Bestrahlungstherapie.
Haben Sie auch Chemotherapie?
Nein, keine Chemotherapie, nur Bestrahlungstherapie.
Vor vier Monaten war ich zur Kontrolle beim Onkologen.
Und der hat gesagt, zu weit findet er das in Ordnung.
War da nichts Auffälliges.
Das letzte Mal, vor vier Monaten waren Sie in Kontrolle.
Und seit wann haben Sie diese Bronchitis in Ordnung?
Bronchitis habe ich schon mindestens 7, 8 Jahre.
Und die Operation war für anderthalb Jahre?
Ja.
Haben Sie noch andere Erkrankungen?
Ja, ich muss noch ein Medikament einnehmen für die Schilddröse,
weil ich an der Schilddröse operiert worden bin.
Das wird dann auch immer mal wieder kontrolliert,
dass die Schilddröse nicht wieder groß wird und wächst.
Aber sonst habe ich keine anderen Erkrankungen,
bis auf meine Operationen.
War Ihre Schilddröse gering?
Ja.
Die Schilddröse war auf der rechten Seite vergrößert.
Und in der Vergrößung war auch ein Knoten.
Das war, glaube ich, ein kalter Knoten.
Dann musste das operiert werden.
Aber es war alles gutartig und es ist gut verlaufen.
Das war vor 10 Jahren.
Und seit her nehme ich jeden Morgen eine Tablette,
damit die Schilddröse nicht wieder wächst und groß wird.
Wie ist der Name dieser Tablette?
Die Tablette heißt Euthyrox 75.
Sie nehmen morgens ein.
Ein Tablett morgens, ja.
Aus dieser genannten Medikamente nehmen Sie noch andere Medikamente ein.
Nein, sonst nehme ich da keine anderen Medikamente.
Sie nehmen nur örtrucks ein.
Und haben Sie noch andere Erkrankungen?
Nein, Erkrankungen.
Ich bin operiert worden bei der ersten Geburt,
also bei der Geburt meiner Tochter.
Das war vor 30 Jahren, da hatte ich ein Kaiserschnitt.
Ein Kaiserschnitt.
Haben Sie irgendeine Allergie oder Unverträglichkeit?
Nein, ich vertrage alles.
Ich habe geraucht bis zu der,
als das mit dem Bronchalkrebs bekannt wurde.
Bis dahin habe ich lange geraucht, ja und zu viel.
Ich habe mindestens 30 Jahre geraucht
und jeden Tag eine Schachtel Zigaretten.
Aber seit anderthalb Jahren,
seit der Operation, rauche ich nicht mehr.
Sie haben eine sehr gute Entscheidung getroffen.
Ja, manche sagen es sei sehr spät,
aber mal schauen, ob ich davon noch profitiere.
Ich denke, es ist nicht so spät.
Ein wenig Erzgerät ist ein großer Schritt für Ihre Gesundheit.
Okay.
Sie trinken Sie Alkoholfrauschproblen?
Ja, aber nicht regelmäßig.
Vielleicht mal am Wochenende ein Glas Wein.
Oder vielleicht kommen zwei Gläserwein, aber nicht mehr.
Nicht jeden Tag, nur am Wochenende.
Bitte nehmen Sie meine nächste Frage nicht persönlich.
Ich muss fragen, ob Sie irgendeine Kontakte mit Drogen hatten.
Nein.
Was sind Sie vom Beruf?
Ich bin vom Beruf Polizistin.
Bis zu der Erkrankung war ich im Außendienst.
Seit der Operation bin ich im Innendienst tätig.
Da muss ich keine Nachtdienste mehr machen.
Ich bin nur noch im Innendienst.
Ich verstehe.
Wie ist Ihr Familienstand?
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Ja, ich bin verheiratet und wohne mit meinem Mann zusammen.
Ich habe eine Frau, die nicht mehr bei uns wohnt.
Sie ist 30 Jahre alt.
Sie lebt in einer anderen Stadt.
Haben Sie ein Kind?
Ja.
Ist sie gesund?
Ja, doch, sie ist gesund.
Jetzt möchte ich einige Fragen zu Ihrer Familie stellen.
Leben Ihren Eltern noch?
Die Mutter lebt noch, die ist 89 Jahre alt.
Sie hat Alterszucker.
Sie hat auch eine schwere Atrose an beiden Hüften.
Aber sie will sich nicht mehr operieren lassen.
Der Vater ist verstorben mit 68 Jahren an Lungenkrebs.
68?
Hatte Ihr Vater noch andere Erkrankungen außer Erkrankungen?
Ja, er hatte hohe Cholesterinwerte.
Er musste auch Medikamente oder Medikamente nehmen.
Er hatte hohe Blutdruck.
Mehr weiß ich jetzt aber nicht.
Ich habe noch einen Bruder.
Ihre Mutter hat nur Zuckerkrankheit und Alterszucker.
Alterszucker und die Atrose.
Ich habe noch einen Bruder, der 60 Jahre alt ist.
Er hat hohe Blutdruck.
Er hat hohe Harnsäure und hat auch mehrere Gichtanfälle gehabt.
Er hat auch eine starke Schuppenflechte.
Sie haben alle Kinderkrankheiten und Covid-19 geimpft?
Ich bin immer regelmäßig bei Betriebsarzt.
Bei der Polizei werden wir untersucht.
Da wird immer nach den Impfungen geschaut.
Da war es so, dass ich gegen alles Notwendige geimpft bin.
Und haben Sie in letzter Zeit einen Unfall?
Nein.
Ich bin nicht gestürzt.
Ich muss fragen, ob Sie Ihre Frauenarzt regelmäßig besuchen?
Ich gehe zu der Frauenärztin regelmäßig zur Vorsorgeuntersuchung.
Das war zuletzt, glaube ich, im Mai.
Im Mai 2024.
Da war so weit alles gut.
Die Frauenärztin war zufrieden.
Das ist gut.
Und wann war Ihre letzte Periode?
Das ist schon mindestens fünf Jahre her.
Ich verstehe.
Ich bin fertig.
Ich habe eine Frage gestellt.
Haben Sie noch andere Fragen?
Möchten Sie noch etwas hinzufügen?
Was kann das sein?
Ich verstehe, dass Sie den Grund ihrer Beschwerden
möglichst schnell wissen wollen.
Aber ich kann Ihnen keine genaue Diagnose nehmen.
Ich habe noch etwas mit dem Grund für die Beschwerden.
so, bin es noch etwas eingefallen. Ich hatte vor ungefähr fünf oder sechs Jahren Beschwerden
am rechten Knie mit dem Meniscus. Da bekam ich beim Orthopäden drei Spritzen und bekam
auch dann Kampengymnastik und dann wurde das besser mit dem Knie. Der Orthopäde meinte,
dass wir ein Lege am Meniscus. Seit fünf oder sechs Jahren. Aber seitdem hatte ich nie Beschwerden.
Jetzt würde ich Sie bitte noch einmal kurz im Martesmerch Platz zu nehmen. Wir rufen Sie in
wenigen Minuten mit der Untersuchung anzufangen. Okay, dann würde ich sagen, haben Sie jetzt mal Zeit.
Ich habe auf meiner Uhr, wenn wir sagen, so um halb sieben, also in zehn Minuten, ist das genug für
Sie, dass Sie zehn Minuten Zeit haben, sich vorzubereiten für die Vorstellung, weil ich bin
dann der Oberarzt. Jetzt bin ich ja noch Frosch-Bullmann und dann bin ich der Oberarzt. Dann haben Sie
jetzt etwas Zeit. Übersetzen Sie die Patientensprache in die Fachsprache, wenn es geht. Ja, und die anderen
Kollegen, die jetzt zugehört haben, heute sind es ja auch recht viele. Vielleicht gibt es noch Fragen.
Haben wir etwas vergessen? Ich habe eine Frage. Sind Sie eine Polizistin? Aber arbeiten Sie im
Büro oder aktiv? Und treiben Sie Sport? Also, seit meiner Operation wegen dem Brontialkrebs bin ich im
Innendienst, also bin ich im Büro. Vorher musste ich immer auch auswärts fahren, im Autostreife
fahren, aber seit der Erkrankung, seit der Operation, arbeite ich im Büro. Sport treibe ich nicht. Nein.
Letzte Zeit sind Sie lange Zeit gereist? Nein, ich war im letzten Frühjahr, war ich mal für eine
Woche in Spanien auf Mallorca und sonst war ich aber, habe ich meine Ferien in Deutschland verbracht.
Hallo, ich habe eine Frage. Ist Ihnen eine bestimmte Allergie bekannt? Nein, Allergien habe
ich nicht. Also, ist mir nicht bekannt. Nein. Danke. Ich habe noch eine andere Frage. Ja, bitte.
Haben Sie oder hatten Sie Pile benutzen oder eingenommen? Können Sie das noch einmal wiederholen?
Oralcontroceptiva oder Pile? Ja, aber nur wenige Jahre. Das habe ich höchstens fünf Jahre eingenommen,
die Pile, glaube ich. Haben Sie eine Medikamente gegen Menopause eingenommen? Nein, nein, habe ich nicht.
Okay, vielen Dank. Wenn Sie bereit sind, können wir natürlich gerne anfangen.
Ich habe den Eindruck, Sie können das gut und Sie sind mit der Frust. Ja, wir können auch gerne jetzt anfangen.
Guten Tag Herr Oberarzt. Ich würde Ihnen gerne eine Patiente vorstellen, wie ich gerade eben in der Ambulanz gesehen habe.
Haben Sie kurz seid? Ja, habe ich. Frau Valentina Strotman, 61 Jahre alt, 164 cm groß, 65 kg schwer.
Die Patiente stört sich bei uns vor Aufgrund seit drei Wochen bestehender, seit zwei Tagen schlimmer gewordener, langsam aufgetretener,
umdrehen und drücken der Schmerzen im Oberschenker, Oberkörper, vom Knie. Die Schmerzen stören nicht aus.
Die Patiente hatte so etwas schon, nicht hatte so etwas schon. Die Patiente habe gegen diese Schmerzen zwei Tabletten,
die sich mit der Obst- und die Proferenz 600 mg eingenommen haben, aber nicht genug geholfen. Das war gestern.
Diese Schmerzen seien besser mit Hochlagerung. Die Patiente berichtet über begleitende Ödeme im Oberschenkel und Hyperthermie.
Die Patiente, die bei der Patiente bekannte, diese Vorerkrankungen, lungeankarsinom, sie haben vor anderthalb Jahren,
wegen dieser lungeankarsinom eine Operation hatte, habe gehabt, und noch eine Strahlungtherapie.
Und bei der Vorerkrankung auch eine chronische Bronchitis bekannt.
Ich unterbreche einmal, und wiederhole einmal, was Sie mir bisher geschildert haben. Korrigieren Sie mich bitte, wenn etwas nicht stimmt.
Frau Valentina Strohtmann ist eine 61-jährige Patientin, die seit drei Wochen über ein Schmerz im distalen Femur klagt.
Sie sagen, Sie starrt Oberchenkel bitte Femur, distaler Femur, also unter Schenkel klagt.
Der Schmerz wird als dumpf und drückend beschrieben. Anfangs war er auf der VRS-Kala zwischen 3 und 4 und jetzt seit zwei Tagen zwischen 6 und 7.
Ibuprofen 600 haben nur begrenzt geholfen, also nur gering geholfen.
Die Patientin leidet seit Jahren unter einer chronischen Bronchitis, in diesem Falle würde ich ruhig sagen, wahrscheinlich unter einer COPD.
Sie brauchen das Wort COPD, aber beim Pulmologen hat ihr ein elektrisches Inhalationsgerät verschrieben.
Liegt ein Unfallereignis vor, ist die Patientin in letzter Zeit gestürzt?
Nein, die Patientin verneinte in letzter Zeit einen Unfall.
Schmerzen, Lokalisation im Bereich des rechten distalen Femurs.
Es findet sich ein Begleitödem in diesem Bereich mit subjektiver Überwärmung.
Sie haben sich der Patientin noch nicht untersucht, sie haben das noch nicht objektiviert.
Die Patientin schildert das.
Im Bereich des Punktum Maximums ein Begleitödem mit Überwärmung.
Fahrt Sie bitte fort.
Die Patientin hat eine schilderöse Operation unterzogen vor zehn Jahren.
Sie nehmen Öttorox, Ältoroxin 75 mg morgens ein.
Das Mittel heißt Öttoroxin, aber das hier heißt Öttorox 75 mg morgens.
Wissen Sie, weshalb die Schilderöse operiert wurde?
Sie hatten Vergrößerung vom Schilderöse.
Sie haben den medizinischen Fachbegriff für Vergrößerte Schilderöse.
Struhma.
Genau, benutzen Sie das ruhig.
Sie haben den Struhma operiert.
Ja, und in dieser Struhma war noch ein Befund drin.
Kalte Knoten.
Ja, und wie heißt dann der Fachbegriff?
Struhma Benidna.
Ja, erst mal eine Struhma nodosa.
Nodosa ist der Knoten.
Struhma nodosa ist die Diagnose.
Es fand sich das rechts.
Wegen einer Struhma nodosa erfolgte vor ungefähr zehn Jahren eine
wahrscheinlich hemityriodektomie, also Schilderösenoperation hin.
Eine halbseitige Schilderösenresekktion oder Entfernung.
Genau, das wissen wir nicht.
Das ist bisher die Schilderung der Patientin.
Aber versuchen Sie, die Fachbegriffe zu nutzen,
möglichst nicht Schilderösenoperationen sagen,
sondern in diesem Falle Thyriodectomie oder hemityriodektomie
bei Struhma nodosa.
Okay, gibt es andere Operationen?
Diese Operation wegen Lungenkarcinom.
Ja, also Bronchalkarcinom, wahrscheinlich.
Bronchalkarcinom, ja.
Vor anderthalb Jahren.
Ja, und noch eine.
Und Sie besuche regelmäßig die Lungenpaarz.
Den Pulmologen, ja.
Pulmologen.
Neumologen.
Aber noch denken Sie daran,
bitte an eine Operation vor 30 Jahren.
Vor 30 Jahren wurde die Tonneergebore.
Ja, ja.
Kreisenschnitt, ich weiß nicht, die Fachbegriffe.
Ja, der Kaiser steht, sagen wir, Sektio.
Sektio.
Ja, oder Sektio cesarea,
Kreiserschnitt, aber Sektio reicht.
Ja, vor 30 Jahren erfolgte eine Sektio.
Ja, das sind die Operationen.
Also vor 30 Jahren eine Sektio,
vor 10 Jahren eine Hemityriodektomie
und vor anderthalb Jahren eine Operation an den Bronchen.
Wir wissen nicht genau, was operiert worden ist.
Ein Kollege hat hier, glaube ich, geschrieben,
Lobectomy, habe ich gesehen.
Wir wissen nicht genau, was da alles operiert wurde.
Das müssen wir dann herausfinden, indem wir Befunde anfordern.
Von dem Arzt oder von den Ärzten.
Aber diese Operation fand statt und vor anderthalb Jahren
die Diagnose Bronchalkazinom.
Ja, gut.
Gibt es sonst Auffälligkeiten bei der Patientin
in Risikofaktoren, raucht die Patientin?
Sie hatte 30 Jahre lang ein Schachtel Ziggaretten geraucht,
seit anderthalb Jahren, seit dieser Operation.
Sie ist nicht traurig.
Ja, Sie können sagen, bis vor anderthalb Jahren
bestand ein Nikotin-Abusus von 30 Packages.
Also die Dosisbeziehung.
30 Jahre lang eine Schachtel pro Tag sagen wir auch 30 Packages.
Gut.
Und seit 18 Monaten besteht Nikotin-Karenz.
Ja, gut.
Was ist die Patientin von Beruf?
Sie ist Polizistin.
Bis diese Operation, Sie haben Oisendienst.
Ja, im Außendienst, ja.
Also musst du im Auto fahren und Nachtschicht und so.
Gut.
Aber jetzt, Sie arbeiten in einem Dienst.
Okay.
Gibt es Auffälligkeiten in der Familienanamnese?
Ja, der Vater, der Patientin.
Er sei mit 6, nicht 6, 1860 am Brunhjalkarsnorn gestorben.
Ja.
Und Ihre Mutter leid an Diabetes meleitroszit 2
und beides sei es Hüftartrose.
Ja, kennen Sie den Begriff von Hüftartrose,
den Fachbegriff?
Ja, der Begriff von Hüftartrose.
Genau, Koktsartrose.
Markieren Sie sich am besten, wenn da steht Hüftartrose,
machen Sie einen Farbmarkierer oder ein Sternchen,
dass Sie das in der Vorbereitungszeit möglichst übersetzen
in Fachsprache.
Unterer Oberschenkel, Oberalbtiskties,
Distala Femur.
Brunhjalkarsnorn, Stromanodosa,
diese Sachen, das ist schon wichtig,
dass Sie da möglichst das in der Prüfung dann auch sagen.
Sie kennen die Worte, aber Sie müssen Sie halt nur einsetzen.
Koktsartrose, beides sei es die Koktsartrose.
Und die Mutter lebt die Mutter noch?
Ja, sie lebt noch.
Und sie ist 89 Jahre alt.
Okay, gibt es Geschwister?
Sie haben ein Brot,
er leidet am Artriellehypertonie,
Artrika,
Artritis urika und psöriasis.
Sehr gut, da haben Sie jetzt die Fachbegriffe alle gut gebracht.
Also der Bruder ist 60 Jahre alt,
er leidet am Artriellehypertonie,
Artritis urika und an einer psöriasis.
Wahrscheinlich psöriasis, vulgaris,
aber jedenfalls psöriasis, es ist die Schuppenflechte.
Gut, was ist denn Ihre Verdachtstiagnose?
Ach so, die Patientin hatte noch angegeben,
ich erinnere noch mal kurz dran,
die Patientin hatte auch angegeben,
vor fünf oder sechs Jahren hatte sie beschwerten
am rechten Knie, am Menismus.
Ja, sagen Sie dann ruhig vor fünf bis sechs Jahren,
bestand eine Kniebeschwerden
im Sinne wahrscheinlich einer Meniscusreizung
oder Meniskopathie,
diese wurde mit Injektionen beim Orthopäden behandelt
und mittels Physiotherapie.
Das war eine Besserung.
Was ist Ihre Verdachtstiagnose?
Aufgrund der Symptomatik
habe ich einen Verdacht auf Metastas des Bronchiarcharsinums.
Okay.
Und als Differenzial Diagnosen
kommen ein Oster-Sarcom,
vielleicht Trombofilebitis.
Okay, gut.
Also mit der Verdachtstiagnose
habe ich eine Verdacht auf eine Ostsehre-Metastase.
Bei Bronchiarcharsinum bin ich sehr einverstanden.
Das kann ja auch mal sehr schnell entstehen.
Und auch wenn die Kontrolle vor vier Monaten in Ordnung war,
man kontrolliert ja nicht immer alles.
Es ist wahrscheinlich keine Skelettssyntographie gemacht worden
oder weil sie keine Beschwerden auch hatte.
Also das war unauffällig.
Es kann auch ein Erguss sein
im Recessus suprapatillaris, also oberhalb des Knies,
vielleicht auch bei Meniscusreizung,
wir wissen es nicht genau,
Trombofilebitis kann eine Rolle spielen.
Aber die Hauptdiagnose Verdacht
ist wahrscheinlich die Verdacht auf Ostsehre-Metastase
bei Bronchiarcharsinum.
Die Vorgeschichte ist da doch ein gewisses Alarmzeichen.
Da muss man zumindest dran denken.
Gerade auch wenn die Beschwerden seit drei Wochen bestehen
und jetzt stärker, stärker geworden sind.
Das ist da vielleicht zu einer
vielleicht drohenden Frakturierung kommt.
Pathologischen Fraktur, das kann schon gut sein.
Ja, danke erst mal, dass Sie sich zur Verfügung gestellt haben.
Sie haben das sehr, die Anamnese sehr ruhig,
sehr strukturiert gemacht.
Ich konnte sie gut verstehen.
Sie haben die 20 Minuten der Anamneseerhebung exakt eingehalten.
Das war gut.
Da sollten Sie nicht zu lange machen.
Also 20 Minuten ist da ja das vorgegebene oder das Wunschlimmit.
Das haben Sie aber gut hingekriegt.
Sie haben jetzt weniger Zeit gehabt, sich vorzubereiten
als in der Prüfung.
Aber nochmal mein Hinweis.
Versuchen Sie möglichst viel,
natürlich in die Fachsprache zu übersetzen.
Und jeder hat vielleicht seine eigene Strategie.
Ich empfehle, wenn da steht, Schmerz am oberchenkel,
am unteren oberchenkel, also am Knie praktisch,
dass Sie erst mal sagen oberchenkel.
Was heißt oberchenkel? Femur.
Dass Sie das möglichst dann gleich hinschreiben
oder sich so bergen, das muss ich jetzt übersetzen.
Weil das ist schon sinnvoll.
Oder der Begriff Bronchalkrebs,
das ist zumindest schreiben Bronchalkarcinon.
Die Hüftarthose als Koksarthose.
Kennen Sie den Begriff der Kniearthose?
Knie.
Gonarthose.
Das sind so sehr häufige Dinge,
die denke ich auch in den Vorerkrankungen
der Patienten vorkommen.
Es gibt leider auch die Älter, die Leute werden,
die haben ja Abthosen, die Menschen.
Koksarthose, das sind sehr häufige Beschwerden.
Das kommt immer wieder, denke ich,
auch in den Fallgeschichten, in den Anamnesen vor.
Ich sollte übersetzen und direkt Fachbegriffe schreiben.
In der Vorbereitung würde ich das so Ihnen empfehlen,
weil sonst vergessen Sie das.
Und dann sagen Sie, ja, die Patientin plagt über Schmerzen
im unteren Oberschenkel.
Das ist ja richtig, aber der Prüfer möchte gerne wissen den Fachbegriff.
Der möchte gerne wissen, was heißt denn der Oberschenkel?
Das ist der Febuhr.
Und am Ende des Febuhrs ist der distale Oberschenkel.
Vorne ist proximal.
Und das Ende ist distal.
Das ist schwierig, das weiß ich,
aber versuchen Sie das System systematisch zu machen.
Und dann habe ich da gar keine Sorge.
Sie haben sich sehr gut ausgedrückt.
Sie haben das auch ruhig gesagt.
Ich konnte, wie gesagt, alles gut verstehen.
Wenn Sie ein Medikament nicht richtig verstehen.
Ich glaube, im Anfang haben Sie das Ältürox nicht richtig verstanden,
weil Sie es waren dann wieder von Ältüroxin.
Ich frage die Patientin, können Sie das bitte noch einmal wiederholen?
Oder können Sie das eventuell Buch stabilieren?
Manche haben ja auch einen Zettel mit.
Aber trotzdem, wenn Sie sich nicht sicher sind,
weil Medikamente müssen, das sollte möglichst stimmen.
Weil das kann dann passieren, dass dann der Prüfer sagt,
oh, das kann gefährlich werden,
wenn Sie ein Medikament vertauschen oder verwechseln.
Wenn Sie nicht sicher sind, sagen Sie ruhig,
Frau Struhtmann, können Sie mir das bitte noch einmal wiederholen?
Oder Buch stabilieren?
Und dass Sie das sicher haben?
Das ist dann wichtig.
Gut, ja. Haben Sie schon einen Prüfungstermin?
Ja, ich habe 23 Jahre.